new at 11 tonight concerns developing in
the southern highlands area which is in
the southwest part of the valley
apparently some people who live there
are turning to social media to express
their frustration
over what they're calling terror in
their own neighborhood
they say a group of young people have
been jumping pedestrians breaking into
cars
and riding their bikes into traffic
while trying to run other cars off the
road
apparently this has been happening for
months now and neighbors are scared to
even walk around outside
they've just wreaked so much havoc
everybody is so scared
and a lot of parents are saying they
don't feel safe like
taking their kid to the park like me
just taking her
you know without your significant other
or some sort of protection
according to neighbors metro has been
notified and so has neighborhood
security
now we weren't able to reach out to
metro today because of the holiday
but we're going to be keeping an eye on
this situation and we'll have
updates for you as we get them